hello and welcome to this video playing
plus from Norway one year for for change
and see what plus is doing next is sex
okay not the Colorado opening over the
f5 yeah but this happen here isn't defy
the move I think black it goes back then
right ninety five is this funny
variation where white can take our value
isn't this the line where white can take
or am I wrong here no here they know he
doesn't have that okay if I'm wrong yet
okay he believes me um yeah they're just
be sure oops sorry just be should be too
good thing I don't have smart move
enabled this would have led to King d to
you touch the king
Wow
it looks weird so i can i can play very
technical now on let's play in the
technical way why not it's just a lot
better so i'd also so Bishop p.m. yeah
why does quite a bit better porn
structure is favorable and the bishop on
age five is just a pretty sorry piece
and so isn't this good threatening g4
what are you doing against it show me
age 6 gives the way they have seven pawn
[Music]
push up g six maybe okay I mean g4 is
still interesting 34 h five minutes not
clear that this knits all that much so
okay so H form wasn't all that effective
this looks interesting at for Bishop c5
1970s h5 still making some sense out of
this yeah Bishop Bishop c5 yeah this is
actually true and he's kind of yeah f5
is something that he might be able to
play now I'm not happy with that I
didn't play that well
now very very badly played actually the
position after move 13 or so was was
excellent for white and this is not much
at all ah not good not good not good
[Music]
[Music]
and how did I miss play that all that
badly pretty awful
my black is better here even though
unbelievable okay that that night if
what stuff was probably wrong oh he
loves me to trade that well that's nice
the bishop on b3 wasn't all that great
I've held but again on the way to e3 and
this na should be roughly equal
check which doesn't mean that it
necessary has necessarily has to be a
draw
currently has the d file
cannot go g-form I'd love to do
something a bit more active okay I
probably should have traded on the cell
nap later sir absolutely too superficial
the whole game actually why do I allow
root do you want I don't know not sure
how bad this really is it's clearly not
not necessary to do
trying for C for him time morning mm-hmm
yes f4 I mean I always see the moves but
check right right after i get f for him
to break through at the end
yeah I should be equal or can I do
something here probably not yeah it's
just a draw draw offered game drawn yeah
there was a pretty awful game I mean
from start to finish yeah here here
black is basically busted and the
position is totally terrible and I
played it so badly that that that he got
a good position out of it yeah does this
this whole plan is probably wrong 95 is
given by the comp s is just just not
good you can even question h4 I mean age
for it at some points but I can just
play normally here not not weaken the
kingside at all h was really liked by
the engine now night a form and then be
should be too that's interesting for
enough for Bishop f5 so it probably was
good but right it's also just in
fantastic shape with normal moves just
like this and then just play normal
stuff this is a terrible piece and he's
got a bad structure and it was really
awful here everything was ok I'm and f5
now I think the engine doesn't agree but
I think black is better here it's just
more active rook h3 is an interesting
move for root g 3
[Music]
something I did not did see at all Josh
yeah it's probably equal ich Kenne
thought he had this f4 move that was
really scary yeah I thought a form check
justice and I thought you might have the
breakthrough him check like this this
ng5 but I'm just I'm just I am just
about controlling entity yeah this is a
draw job I didn't use this opening to my
advantage unfortunately okay thanks for
watching
[Music]